Eye-popping, thick-rimmed,
and instantly recognizable,
Bubbles’ glasses in the hit cult TV show
“Trailer Park Boys” are as tied to his
character as much as his love for cats. But
how did Bubbles acquire his signature look?
"Trailer Park Boys" started as a grassroots
project that slowly grew into a cult classic,
and despite its popularity, it still
checks many of the requisite boxes for
cult status. After the show became a hit on
Netflix, “Trailer Park Boys” garnered a loyal
fanbase that fell in love with the likes
of Julian, Ricky, Bubbles, and Mr. Lahey.
"Trailer Park Boys" may basically
be kind-of-sort-of mainstream now,
but no matter how many episodes the fans
consume, die-hards and first-timers alike
may find themselves wondering one particular
question: What's up with Bubbles' glasses?
There's no doubt that the well-meaning Bubbles,
who is played by Mike Smith, is a massive breakout
character. And those extra-thick Coke bottle
specs of his are almost too good to be true. So,
where did the eyewear come from? Did the makers
of the show run against their lo-fi production
values and commission the glasses? Or did
they luck out by finding the glasses that,
let's face it, look more or less like Bubbles
found them dirt cheap at a yard sale somewhere?
As luck would have it, the latter option actually
isn't too far from the iconic glasses' true origin
story. Here's how the makers of "Trailer
Park Boys" came up with Bubbles' glasses.
Mike Clattenburg, the creator of "Trailer Park
Boys," told Sharp Magazine that he hired Mike
Smith to do sound for the feature
film that gave birth to the series,
which was shot in 1998. At his house, Smith put
on the infamous glasses and eased effortlessly
into character. Clattenburg liked what
he saw, and as they say, a star was born.
John Paul Tremblay, who plays Julian,
the muscle-bound trailer park resident
who wears black shirts and always
has a glass of rum and Coke in hand,
is also enthused about the way Smith
introduced Bubbles to them. He said,
"[Mike Smith] totally developed
that character. He threw those
glasses on one day, and we were like,
Wow. This guy needs to be on the show.”
“I don’t know how you passed your eyetest
son, but you can’t see jack sh*t.”
In the very same interview, Smith
himself explained how he came to
possess those sweet frames. Smith explained,
"My girlfriend at the time
was in Texas visiting family,
and they went to an estate sale and she found
these glasses. They were 50 cents, and she knew
that I would think they were funny because they
were so thick, so she bought them as a joke."
Showcase wasn't as convinced about Bubbles
as the makers of the show were at first,
but Clattenburg eventually managed to persuade
the channel to include the character in the show,
though he had to make a short film starring an
early version of Bubbles to do so. In hindsight,
this was probably worth it, as
Clattenburg feels that "Trailer
Park Boys" might not have succeeded at
all without the inclusion of Bubbles.
While the glasses are no doubt an instrumental
part of what just might be the single most
important character in "Trailer Park
Boys," Smith had to suffer for his art,
because Bubbles' signature eyewear is just about
as comfortable to use as you'd expect. However,
he eventually learned to deal with
them. Smith told Big Issue in 2013,
"They give you a proper whopping headache,
but now when I put them on, my brain
turns off my eye pain somehow."